heute stellen wir euch den öffentlichen
nahverkehr in berlin vor
berlin hat einen gut ausgebauten
öffentlichen verkehr
unser erstes thema sind die
verschiedenen arten von verkehrsmitteln
ist urbanen die waren meist unter ehre
manchmal jedoch auch über erde 42 an der
eberswalder straße
es gibt auch s-bahnen die etwas
schneller fahren als im waren diese s
bahn fährt jetzt zum beispiel vom
flughafen schönefeld in ungefähr 30
minuten die berühmte es war es die
ringbahn die ringbahn fährt in einer
stunde um die ganze stadt herum
es waren zwei bahnen parallel die s41
und s42 in beide richtungen
die s41 fährt rechts herum und die s 42
kehrt links herum
eine dritte möglichkeit sind die tram
dramen sind straßenbahnen die direkt auf
der straße fahren fans gibt es nur im
ehemaligen ostberlin
deshalb hat man hier einen kleinen
vorteil
außerdem gibt es noch busse aber ich
benutze sie eigentlich nur nach wenn die
u bahn nicht mehr fahren aber nicht beim
letzten mal
da hat der busfahrer mich mich
mitgenommen weil ich ein fahrrad dabei
hatte er meinte er würde keine fahrräder
mitnehmen
das stimmt aber gar nicht er war einfach
nur unfreundlich
er hat mich dann stehen gelassen und ich
musste ein taxi nach hause nehmen
jetzt zeigen wir euch wie man von a nach
b kommt
entweder ihr guckt auf eine karte und
rechnet euch selber auto von einem punkt
zum mieten kommt oder ihr ladet euch
einfach die bvg app herunter in der bvg
app geht ihr auf fahrplan dann gibt mir
eine station ein
entweder zwei stationen oder eine
station und eine adresse und die app
sucht euch die besten verbindungen
wenn ihr zum beispiel adresse eingibt
gibt euch die app auch an ob ihr ein
teil mit der bahnfahrt und ein teil zu
fuß geht hier zum beispiel müsst ihr 16
minuten mit der tram fahren und neun
minuten zu fuß gehen um diese adresse zu
erreichen
unser letztes thema sind tickets jetzt
wird kompliziert nein so kompliziert ist
das eigentlich gar nicht am besten kauft
ihr auch eure tickets über die bvg app
es ist viel einfacher als sich tickets
am automaten zu kaufen
selbst wenn ihr nur drei tage in der
stadt seit falls ihr aber ein internet
kritiker seit und angst vor handys und
es hat zeige ich euch trotzdem riemann
die tickets an einem guten alten
automaten kauf als erstes dürft ihr euch
nicht verwirren lassen
ihr braucht wahrscheinlich nur den
bereich aber in der innenstadt von
berlin bc also der c bereich ist
außerhalb sie benutzt ihr nur wenn ihr
zum flughafen schönefeld fahrt wir
konzentrieren uns also auf den bereich
aber jetzt müsst ihr wissen ob ihr ein
einzelfahrschein
eine kurzstrecke oder eine tageskarte
braucht wenn ihr mehr als dreimal fahrt
90 eine tageskarte
sie kostet sieben euro wenn ihr ein
normales ticket kauft ist das ein
einzelfahrschein zwei euro 80 eine fahrt
zwei stunden gültig wenn ihr nur drei
stationen fahrt mit der u-bahn oder
sechs stationen mit der tram rentier
kurzstrecke fahren ein euro 70 und wenn
ihr oft fahrt und sparen volt sowie
amish und kari
dann kaufte ihr immer vier karten auf
einmal dann spart ihr nämlich neun euro
für vier tickets normale ticket oder
kurzstrecke vier fahrten kurzstrecke
fünf euro 60 hier mal fertig das waren
alle tickets die zur verfügung stehen
wenn ihr also nach berlin kommt müsst
ihr jetzt was ihr machen müsst was noch
nützlich ist ist zu wissen wo man
überhaupt tickets kaufen kann
bei u bahnen und s bahnen stehen solche
automaten auf dem bahnsteig bei tram
stehen sie in der bahn u bahn und s bahn
nicht
da kann man nicht einsteigen und in der
bahn erstmals gibt kaufen
das ist sehr wichtig zu wissen noch
bequemer ist ein picknick in einem kiosk
oder später zu kaufen
an einem solchen weg vw zeichen könnt
ihr erkennen auf 14
tickets verkauft oder nicht klar war
unser video über öffentliche
verkehrsmittel in berlin
wir hatten es hat euch gefallen wenn ihr
unsere arbeit unterstützen möchte werde
ich doch gerne ein patch in das könnt
ihr hier machen uns abonniert unbedingt
firmen darüber freuen uns sehr dass
könnt ihr hier machen
bis freitag nächster woche